خلص تقرير لمنظمه العفو الدوليه صدر اليوم
الى ارتفاع وصفه
بالصادمة ذلك اثناء الاحتجاجات وعمليات
الدهم والاعتقالات وحرمت الجرحى من
الاسعاف الطبي وحققت المنظمه في اربع
حالات بارزه استخدمت فيها القوات
الاسرائيليه القوه المميته غير المشروعه
وقعت ثلاث منها في اكتوبر تشرين الاول
والرابعه في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني واسفرت
عن مقتل 20 فلسطينيا بصوره غير مشروعه من
بينهم سبعه اطفال كما وجدت ابحاث العفو
الدوليه ان القوات الاسرائيليه عرقلت
تقديم المساعده الطبيه للاشخاص الذين
اصيبوا بجروح هددت حياتهم وهاجمت اولئك
الذين حاولوا مساعده الجرحى الفلسطينيين
بما فيهم المسعفون وخلال الاشهر القليله
الماضيه صعدت اسرائيل عمليات الدهم
المميته في انحاء الضفه الغربيه وتصاعدت
التوترات بشكل
كبير